All right, can I take
your order?
Excuse me.
What would you like sir?
Can you wait?
Isn't that your job?
Aren't you a waiter?
Hey, could you turn your phone
down kid, this is a restaurant?
It just so happens
I have anxiety.
That means I have trouble
being around assholes
who won't leave me alone.
Oh, hello Eric.
Shut up, I have anxiety.
Hey kid. Hey kid!
I'm on my phone!
You're about to get hit
by a car.
All right, that's it.
Everyone stop the
(bleep).
Stop right now!
Listen up people,
I have anxiety.
That means I'm in my shell
and have a hard time
expressing myself.
I find it difficult
to engage with others,
so everyone shut the
(bleep)
up, because my anxiety
is up here right now.